great to have you out here on this
carpet my gosh it's quite the reunion it
is quite the reunion
um I think this is also the first red
carpet I've been on for a movie premiere
in like possibly many many many years
what
what carpet Scarlet
T I love them yeah
um I do I guess it was like maybe a
quarantine maybe that yeah that was sort
of that one and you have some little
ones I mean I got a baby too girl life's
been busy it's been busy yeah and this
world that West creates is something
else you play Midge in this Midge is a
movie star something you know a thing or
two about I'd say
you'll share a similar approach in your
craft says movie star
um I I don't know I never thought about
how she would have brought I guess
probably because I did have to prepare a
piece that she was working on so I think
we probably do she's she's a sociopath
so hopefully we have that not in common
yeah you know right never if I was a
sociopath I probably wouldn't be able to
tell you anyway right right so we don't
know we don't know I do a nude scene you
want to see it
did I say yes
the wildest thing you've done to try to
land a role to try to land a role I mean
Brian Cranston told me he put his hand
through a wall definitely didn't get a
call back on that one oh my yeah um yeah
that sounds extreme
um I the raciest thing I've done
oh I mean I've done a lot of weird
screen tests for Stuff
um really were you prep yeah I did
um I did a screen test for
um uh the movie Gravity that Sandra
Bullock is fantastic in and
um but I had to be in like the full
whole space suit name and sort of
pretend I was kind of like floating in
space even though I was just sitting in
a chair with a helmet on and everyone
else is in folding chairs I think I was
also sitting in a folding chair but um
so what yeah it was it was it was uh but
that's my job right I have to suspend my
disbelief oh my gosh I love seeing you
and your hubby Colin at can how exciting
was it to experience that with him and
then also to receive that six minute
standing ovation I mean you're standing
there receiving all those claps all
those cameras watching your every moves
for six minutes what was that like
mentally I know I mean somehow I think
because Wes is so uncomfortable it
somehow makes me feel better really
okay dude that's all there oh my gosh
and finally the children in this film
they're brainiacs are obsessed with
let's see space inventions is there
anything that your kids are like
brainiacing and obsessing over in real
life
um brainiacking no I mean
trying to think my son my son is very
talkative yeah um and he's not he's not
he's not yet to but he did tell me the
other day that his clothing was all wet
and I was like did you just take that
interesting very verbose
foreign